اجرى امير دوله قطر الشيخ تميم بن حمد
الثاني مباحثات في الدوحه مع رئيس دوله
الامارات العربيه المتحده الشيخ محمد بن
زايد
واقيلا ديوان الاميري القطري من البوم حسن
تركزات على العلاقات بين البلدين والسبل
الكفيله بدعمها وتوطيضها في مختلف
المجالات واضاف انه جرس استعراض تطورات
الاحداث على الساحتين الاقليميه والدوليه
وتبادل وجوهات النظر خلال عدد من القضايا
ذات الاهتمام المشترك
عقد الشيخ تميم بن حمد الثاني امير دوله
قطر والشيخ محمد بن زايد ال نهيان رئيس
دوله الامارات جلسه مباحثات رسميه في
الديوان الاميري بالدوحه وبحسب بيان
الديوان الامير القطري فقد بحث الجانبان
خلال الجلسه تطوير علاقات التعاون المشترك
بين البلدين وسبل دعمها في مختلف المجالات
اضافه الى تعزيز العمل الخليجي المشترك
كما تم استعراض تطورات الاحداث على
الساحتين الاقليميه والدوليه وتبادل وجهات
النظر حيل حدث من القضايا ذات الاهتمام
المشترك من جانبه وخلال تغريده لها اعرب
رئيس الامارات عن تهاني بمناسبه استضافه
قطر لبطوله كاس العالم الجاريه كما اشاد
بنجاح قطر الاستثنائي في تنظيم واحتضان
مثل هذه البطوله العالميه هذا وقد سبق
اجرى وافتان من دوله الامارات ودوله قطر
مباحثات رسميه في اللوحه لتوطيد العلاقات
بين الجانبين ومتابعه تنفيذ بيان قمه
العلا الخليجيه وذلك قبل ايام من هذه
الزياره ويعد الاجتماع الثالث لمتابعه ما
جاء في بيان العلا الذي صدر في المملكه
العربيه السعوديه وتعد هذه الزياره الاولى
للرئيس الاماراتي الى قطر منذ تواليه
منصبه كرئيس للبلاد وتوقيع اتفاق العلا في
السعوديه في يناير من العام الماضي
الشيخ محمد بن زايد قطر بنجاح بطوله كاس
العالم لكره القدم وقال الشيخ محمد بن
زايد انه بحث العلاقات بين البردين وسبلت
عزيزها وتطيرها بما يكذب المصالح المشتركه
وقد رحب امير دوله قطر الشيخ تميم بن حمد
الثاني بزياره رئيس دوله الامارات الشيخ
محمد بن زايد الى دوحه وقال امير دوله قطر
في تغريده على تويتر انه جرت تبادل وجهات
النظر بشان القضايا الاقليميه والدوليه
وفي مقدمتها سبلوا دعم الامن والاستقرار
في المنطقه